there's some pretty dire downstream
effects to all of the coved panic at
this point in time
there are there are reports of soaring
energy costs that have been raising
concerns about us inflation in the
economy
we have a huge bottleneck at the ports
and a lot of that is due to staffing
shortages according to the new york
times
the the
ports all around the world are now
involved in the great supply chain
disruption they're running out of places
to put things at the largest ports in
the united states as major reports
contend with a staggering pileup of
cargo but what seemed like a temporary
phenomenon a traffic jam that would
eventually dissipate is increasingly
viewed as a new reality
that could require a substantial
refashioning of the world's shipping
infrastructure
ships are waiting at sea for more than
nine days at the savannah port on a
recent afternoon more than 20 ships were
stuck in the queue anchored up to 17
miles off the coast in the atlantic such
lines have become common around the
globe from the more than 50 ships
marooned last week in the pacific near
la
to smaller numbers bobbing off terminals
in the new york area to hundreds way
laid off ports in china the turmoil in
the shipping industry and the broader
crisis in supply chains is showing no
signs of relenting it stands as annoying
source of worry throughout the global
economy challenging once hopeful
assumptions of a vigorous return to
growth as vaccines limit the spread of
the pandemic the disruption explains why
germany's industrial fortunes are
sagging why inflation is a a cause for
concern among central bankers why
american manufacturers are now waiting a
record 92 days on average to assemble
the parts and raw materials they need to
make their goods according to the
institute of supply management
on the surface the upheaval appears to
be a series of intertwined product
shortages because shipping containers
are in short supply in china factories
depending on chinese-made parts and
chemicals in the rest of the world have
had to limit production but the
situation at the port of savannah
attests to a more complicated and
insidious series of overlapping problems
it's not merely the goods or scares it's
that products are stuck in the wrong
places separated from where they are
supposed to be by stubborn and
constantly shifting barriers
the shortage of finished goods at
retailers represents the flip side of
the containers stacked on ships marooned
at sea and massed on the riverbanks the
pileup in warehouses is itself a
reflection of shortages of truck drivers
needed to carry goods to their next
destinations
the supply chain is overwhelmed and
inundated
says one of the supply chain managers in
one of the ports it's not sustainable at
this point everything is out of whack
again some of this is due to the massive
lack of labor
early this year when shipping prices
spiked and containers became scarce the
trouble was widely viewed as the
momentary result of pandemic lockdowns
with schools and offices shut americans
were stocking up on home office gear and
equipment for basement gyms drawing
heavily on factors in asia once life
reopened global shipping was supposed to
return to normal but half a year later
the congestion is worse with nearly 13
percent of the world's cargo shipping
capacity tied up by delays
many businesses now assume the pandemic
has fundamentally altered commercial
life in permanent ways those who might
never have shop for groceries or
clothing online have gotten a taste of
the convenience many are likely to
retain the habit maintaining pressure on
the supply chain
also the supply chain disruption has
imposed new frictions
because the upheaval on the seas is
slowing delivery it's limiting sales and
it's having significant downstream
effects and again a large part of this
is when you tell people they don't have
to go back to work they don't go back to
work according to the wall street
journal over the weekend the labor
department on friday reported another
disappointing month for employment the
problem wasn't a dearth of job the
question is where the hell are the
workers
employers added a mere 194 000 jobs in
september that's the second negative
monthly surprise in a row the
unemployment rate fell sharply to 4.8
from 5.2 but that's because 183 america
183 000 americans dropped out of the
workforce so we added as many jobs as
people who dropped out of the workforce
there are now five million fewer
americans employed than before the
pandemic lockdowns three million of
those people have permanently left the
workforce
the number of americans unable to work
because their employer closed or lost
business dropped 600 000 from august
covet cases declined by a third many
industries unaffected by the virus also
failed to add workers so what exactly is
happening
one possible culprit is government and
employer vax mandates that set
ultimatums for workers
president biden's vaccine order first
applied to nursing homes those lost jobs
this month many state and local school
districts have imposed mandates state
and local education employment fell 161
000. the white house claims the vaccine
mandates will boost job growth by
getting people comfortable with going
back to work but they're paying people
to stay home and a lot of the people who
would go back to work because they're
not worried are now out of jobs
democrats have also made quitting an
easier economic option says the wall
street journal pandemic enhanced
unemployment benefits ended in early
september but that was one week before
labor's monthly jobless survey ended
next month might provide better data but
there's still many other federal pay
financial payments that don't require
work including a 300 monthly allowance
per child food stamps and rental
assistance many people have saved some
of their transfer payments now democrats
are promising more
inflation may also be tilting at the
scale to leisure instead of work
average hourly earnings are rising fast
they are 7.4 percent at an annualized
rate but wage growth after inflation has
been declining because food and energy
prices are wildly up
the lack of workers is cr is creating a
drag on the economy slowing production
contributing to supply-side strains
shipped our back ships are backed up in
ports because there aren't workers to
unload and transport them where they
need to go and democrats of course are
planning trillions of dollars in new
taxes and spending in order to fix all
this meanwhile we have an energy
situation this is just back to the 1970s
here
the soaring energy prices i mean they're
really up crude oil is up 64 this year
it's at a seven year high natural gas
prices have doubled over the past six
months to a seven year high heating oil
is up 68 this year prices at the pump
are up nearly a buck over the past 12
months to a national average of just
over three bucks a gallon coal prices
are at records this is according to the
wall street journal and meanwhile the
biden administration is like what if we
made energy more expensive through green
mandates
for consumers it's like a tax says
economist catholic boasts jansec of
oxford econ oxford economics while
consumers will likely be squeezed the
energy price rise would have to be
extreme and prolonged to halt the
economic recovery but more likely we'd
see growth decelerate more or a longer
pause before growth resumes
so we have shortages in supply chains we
have shortages of energy
we have increased taxes and increased
regulation and businesses who are not
investing as much because they don't
literally literally don't know how much
money they have to hold back before
taxes
and joe biden continues along this path
joe biden is just going to continue this
and it's it's a bold move cotton we'll
see how it works out for him
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content